when Trajan and swim swim came on board
we talked at length about what it looks
like to raise this family and so with
all of their input with the incredible
front office we have they're here on the
right everything we do is about adding
members to this family that are
reflective of the same values that Zions
family have instilled in here him and
fortunately we are blessed
drue Holliday is one of those guys and
when I said last night when we did our
first media availability that drew
Holiday is the face of this franchise he
is that dude this is his team and we are
all going to be made of the same stuff
and that means we sacrifice whatever it
takes to win basketball games and
because Zion is the person he is all he
wants to do is contribute to that so
people looked at me kind of oddly and it
got ran many times again he is not the
savior of the pelicans franchise and
he's certainly not the savior of the
Saints pelicans family mrs. Benson and
her team have done a remarkable job with
the Saints building a winner
a team that wins at the very highest
level with the best front office
anywhere with the best coaching staff
anywhere they've laid a model out very
clearly for us to follow so there is no
narrative that should exist that we are
a stepchild of that what we are as
beneficiaries of the fact that they
already know how to do great they know
how to do magical it's our job to do
that on this side and Zion will
contribute to that just like all the
rest of us will know it's a it's an
honor to really to to have an
opportunity to the coach a player like
Zion and not just from his ability
standpoint just from you know the
character that he has when you start to
to try to turn our franchise into a
consistent winner you got to have the
talent but you have to have people that
have the character that he has and so
just adding him to the mix along with
other people like drew Holliday
you know I think that we're well on our
way to doing that and I think that it's
going to be enjoyable to see the style
of basketball that we'll play he more
than fits into it we're going to be
exciting to watch you know the fan base
that we have here you learn that they're
really really dedicated and and and they
will follow you all the way and I think
what mrs. Benson says that if you love
the city of them more than love you back
and I can't imagine anything that you
wouldn't do to make this city love you
so you don't get the coach guys I like
this very often and when you're lucky
enough to have a generational player
like that that you're going to be able
to coach you know you relish to just the
honor of being able to coach a guy like
that